und was exklusives wie bild erfuhr plant
die bundeskanzlerin jetzt die 3g regeln
auch auf die deutsche bahn anzuwenden
das heißt keine reisen mit der bahn für
alle die nicht geimpft getestet oder
gelesen sind diese regel die angela
merkel sich davor stellt lässt sich in
gar keiner weise irgendwie kontrollieren
es würde für das weiß jeder der mit dem
zug fährt zu totalem chaos führen wer
soll diese tests überprüfen wann soll
man diese test überprüfen stehen dann
die armen schaffner an jeder ecke und
lassen sich den test zeigen oder den
impfausweis oder wenn der zug abgefahren
ist in berlin hauptbahnhof zwischen
berlin und spannendes kontrolle und in
spandau speist man die leute alle wieder
raus die keinen test vorlegen können auf
so eine idee kann tatsächlich nur jemand
kommt der seit vielen vielen jahren
gefahren wird und mit dem alltag
bahnfahren rein gar nichts mehr zu tun
hat ich glaube nicht dass diese regel
jemals kommen wird und ich halte sie in
der langen reihe irrsinniger regeln für
die mit abstand irrsinnig rassisten die
evidenz dass jemand sich überhaupt in
bahnen und zügen oder im öffentlichen
nahverkehr
ansteckt und dies relativ gering da gibt
es gute studien aus oxford auch paris in
der metro wurde sehr genau geschaut ob
es das hot spots gibt die in der bahn
entstehen und das oder in der metro
entstehen und das ist eigentlich nicht
der fall die häufigsten ansteckung
passieren immer noch im privaten
haushalt auch trotz impfung und trotz
genesenen status ich glaube wir sehen
hier ja ein ein bizarres und mich
beunruhigen das bedürfnis der
bundesregierung menschen zwangs zu
schützen und teilweise das sagt die
regierung ja auch vor sich selbst zu
schützen vor etwas und das zeigen diese
zahlen ja ganz eindeutig wo man durchaus
zweifel haben kann ob es noch aufgabe
der regierung ist uns davor zu schützen
wenn wir diese entkoppelung von
erkrankungen und hospitalisierung und
quasi keinen todesfällen sehen dann muss
man ja die frage stellen muss der staat
mit so drastischen maßnahmen mich davor
schützen dass wir am ende nichts
passiert besonders wenn ich mich impfen
lassen kann und das ist das was dort
gerade passiert und meine antwort darauf
ist ganz klar nein muss das staatlich
sollte der staat nicht der staat schützt
mich auch nicht davor dass ich über eine
vielbefahrene straße gehe ja das risiko
an koronaren als jemand der sie geimpft
hat ist geringer als nahezu alle anderen
alltags risiken vor denen uns der staat
vollkommen zu recht nicht schütze und es
gibt nicht nur eine koppelung zwischen
infektion und
hospitalisierung und sterbezahlen es
gibt auch eine kopplung von deutschland
und dem rest europas in anderen
europäischen ländern sehen wir volle u
bahn komplett ohne masken in
großbritannien zum beispiel in den
skandinavischen ländern alle anderen
länder machen das was aus meiner sicht
der richtige weg ist zurück ins normale
leben das nunmal lebensrisiken
beinhaltet und angela merkel macht auf
den letzten meter ihrer kanzlerschaft
noch mal eine schippe mit regeln drauf
und wie gesagt wenn sie mal bahn fahren
würde und mal versuchen würde zu
erkennen wer soll diese regel den
umsätzen dann könnte die antwort nur
laufen lauten niemand kann diese regeln
umsetzen und sie ist absolut nicht
praktikabel
[Musik]